I'd like to welcome all the members of
our public to our exact session today
both from the school boards Association
you're
uh also for the committee uh we're going
to I I don't know have any information
on this supposed storm we're heading our
way here in terms of how that might
impact us but if
if something happens we have a number of
bills on Wednesday we're going to have
to exec and this is happening in another
committee too and so those bills are
going to have to be addressed so try to
prepare for driving on Wednesday
unless it's so buried out there for some
reason that um
we'll have to find out I have to talk to
leadership and find out what they plan
on doing with that situation represent
Tanner maybe if it's scheduled a little
later in the morning it would be better
too they're trying to get here
yeah we could do that from our
perspective on on the Wednesday
um Mike my concern is if if Wednesday's
out of the equation because of something
what do we do the the rules which we
have is that
we have to have the bills out by
at four o'clock on on basically or noon
on the 16th
but we have a session that's been put
into the 16th and representative Sanborn
in Hercules having the same problems we
are because they they have some bills
which are causing a lot of discussion we
had the 93 bills and we're just about
there so we came up against this once
before on this committee and what we
ended up having to do is the bill we
hadn't done we had to retain it
there was no other way of doing it so it
didn't go before we just kept the bill
on the committee and dealt with it in
November
and we have not retained that many bills
in this committee this year we've been
really short on it last year we retained
13 bills and and uh so at any rate so
let's get on with the business of today
I'm going to jump over HP 331 uh I have
to again find a little bit more
information on that because we we
skipped it
um last week because of the bill which
we had on the floor which we did resolve
regarding the 300 to 350 percent of the
medium family income for the EFA program
this program this one is where there is
no cap on the EFA program I need to get
some more insight as far as where we're
going on that so
um I will jump over that now
um 515 is the next bill up that I see
here
and so I would like look to a motion
from representative pentanyl on 515 this
is relative to education Freedom
accounts
does everybody have a copy of it in
front of you there
representative Penner now
or representative McDonald
thank you both um I move on to pass is
there a second representative
thank you uh representative McDonald
would you like to speak to your motion
uh yes please 515 makes minor changes to
statute to keep the EFA program
consistent I think there's always a
value to updating our statutes to make
consistency and minor changes as some
members of the committee have urged more
transparency in the EFA program keeping
statue consistent would go along with
transparency thank you
from the second any discussion yes thank
you I just want to add that this helps
clarify the statute regarding the EF the
education Freedom accounts it adds
clarification to the authority and the
accountability of the scholarship
Association and during the hearing there
was some question about line 29 on page
two using the word intentional and I
think that that just brings that word up
to par with the use of intentional
online 30 on page two which is already
in statute suspected cases of
intentional and substantial that just
makes it
the same across all the statutes okay
that's represent Luna
thank you very much
um I'm going to be uh I'm not certainly
not going to be supporting the ought to
pass on on here um because I think we've
got some very
um clear language but not but not sure
how it applies or how it would apply uh
with respect to State adequacy Grant
payments to schools
um when an EFA student may be maybe
taking
um taking classes outside of their EFA
at their local school because they can
be I believe a part-time or less than 50
percent student at their local schools
that's injected in two places once in
section four and then again in in
section
uh
again in section five
um
and um and then it uh it continues to
perpetuate the use of intentional and
substantial in fact it adds intentional
in an area which is an possible standard
for pretty much anybody other than the
Department of Justice to uh to determine
so I think the bill continues to
further the um the the lack of
accountability and lack of of
um of you know any ability to detect
fraud in the program as has been seen in
other states but you know you can't
catch fraud if you if you um prevent um
any anybody's ability to um
detect fraud so so uh you know so I'm
certainly not going to be supporting the
ought to pass
this question represented like us
I just wanted to address the sections
that said the department shall make no
State adequacy Grant payment to the
school for those things and that's put
in there because
the EFA makes the payments and that way
there won't be double dipping and since
the money comes out of the students EFA
the state should not also be paying that
money a second time it paid it once to
put it into the EFA
thank you representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair just to comment
briefly on the on the language
surrounding the uh the intention of
fraud I don't think anybody wants um
there to be fraud in this program but I
think what this bill is trying to do in
the language is trying to do is bring it
in line with what you would typically
find in criminal law something called
men's Ria or the the criminal mindset is
something you typically have to prove in
order to prove somebody has committed a
crime that's true of murder it's true of
any number of crimes and the only reason
I can think of to not want to have to
prove that somebody actually had an
intention will be to prosecute somebody
from making a mistake I don't think
that's something we really want to do we
want to prosecute people for actual
fraud not for making mistake especially
a mistake that can be corrected
further discussion from the committee
representative luno thank you very much
Mr chair and I appreciate that but um
but when when doing prosecution and
um and and uh and consideration of men's
Reya and the intentionality that
prosecution is done by the Department of
Justice not by a um a third party
contractor
and this applies to a third party
further discussion
not seeing any uh
representative dry is going no excuse me
this is going to be reps cordiello
represent dry you keep the record of
oh okay yes uh reps and Allison had to
step out and I'm going to wait for him
to get back so we'll just you know take
a break here until the time that he
comes back thank you you're welcome I
didn't see him gone yeah I understand
why
foreign
okay we have a motion on the table on uh
five one five and the motion is
ought to pass and 515 is relative to the
education Freedom accounts
uh so the motion on the on before us
right now is ought to pass uh Madam
clerk are you ready to call the roll
uh why don't you start out that was
because with my name first you you first
I will start first seeing that our vice
chair is not here yeah
so if you're calling me I I say chair
chairman Ladd yes
representative verbal yes representative
blackis yes representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortielo yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Ellison no representative Woodcock
representative Hall no representative
Balboni no representative cascad and no
representative Damon no
10 years 10 Nays
Mr chair I'll move itl and I suspect
we're headed towards the 1010. I suspect
so okay we have a motion on the table
for made by representative luno second
by represent Myler for itl on this bill
515 any discussion from the maker of the
motion no from the second no further
discussion on the committee not seeing
any amount of clerk
chairman left no
representative erville though
Representative lekkas no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative pattern no representative
course yellow no representative Miler
yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Lino yes representative Ellison yes
representative
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascad and
yes representative Damon yes 10 years 10
days
aren't are there any further discussion
on that emotions not seeing any so we
once are again at no recommendation uh
I'll do the report okay you will do that
in represent McDonald you'll do the
other report
represent dried you got that down
okay the the next bill which we have
before us is 5 30. this is the
withdrawal process from a Cooperative
School District I'm going to hand the
it's relative to withdrawal from a
Cooperative School District represent 40
now is there a motion
yes I'd like to make a motion of ought
I'll second okay
representative parano
representative
okay is there discussion at this point
um well I'd be glad to speak to this but
I'm going to hang uh yes I will speak to
this bill
um hand me back the Gabba I'll speak to
her okay that was back to you we have uh
had many a discussion on the withdrawal
process from a Cooperative School
District
and every time we've done that we've set
up committees to look at that process
and we have come short of being trying
to uh determine a decent remedy to this
what this bill does
um and I'm going to give you a brief
explanation of one District that's had
an issue in the withdrawal process from
a Cooperative School District
I'm going to talk specifically about the
town of Carroll because that's been very
much in the news and uh and uh the whole
process they filed through and about
three times
uh town of Carroll is in the white
mountain region uh School District
and it was formed back in 1963 articles
of agreement were put together in 1963
which involved Carol Dalton Jefferson
Lancaster and Whitefield
at that time when they established the
articles of agreement
they had a a formula based on 60 percent
average daily membership and 40 based on
equalized property valuation
some some cooperatives do it differently
and that's that's in their articles
agreement some might do a totally on
demographics on student population some
may slide more with equalized property
valuation this particular District does
it on 60 40 in terms of population and
since then the population in these towns
has significantly changed
and the population of Carol really has
significantly changed down to about 59
students
that's 4.62 percent of the student body
of that particular Cooperative School
District
based upon the agreement the article
agreement that was put together back in
and
going to today's figures Carol has to
pay on a per pupil basis forty six
thousand thirty five dollars per pupil
in that Cooperative School District
whereas Dalton Jefferson Lancaster and
Whitefield paid nine thousand one
hundred ninety dollars fourteen thousand
seven hundred sixty two dollars five
thousand seven hundred and fifteen
dollars and nine thousand seven hundred
and six dollars respectively
so you can see there's a significant
significant difference between what uh
the town of uh Carol is having to pay
right now and if anybody is driven
through Carroll right now
and I oftentimes do when I'm driving
over towards Berlin I drive up and over
the hump there and through Jefferson and
over I'm sure you know that about that
route there representative cascadden
um you go through Carol and you're
looking at one establishment after
another that is closed down
and yet those properties being so close
to White Mountains and to the ski areas
are still valued High yet the Rev
revenue or the income of those families
is now significantly lower than it was
in the past
so what we have
a situation where Carol has tried to
change the the the way things are funded
and they've even gone to the point where
they've tried to withdraw on not several
times and that's gone from the process
of them voting in their District to the
the total Cooperative board voting and
the Cooperative board as they've always
voted is voted against no so it's been
appealed to the State Board of Education
and the State Board of Education has
heard this
in the most recent appeal process the
State Board of Education said this about
this matter one that the form the White
Mountain Regional School District
continue to engage in constructive
dialogue to boast a Cooperative School
District where five not four districts
participate of of their own volition
they're basically said that it's now
it's time for the legislative to get out
and after you've gone through to and had
your uh Cooperative overall Cooperative
meeting they would also have to have a
super majority and the super majority is
a three-fifths vote and if both agree
then the the district is trying to leave
includes online two a three excuse me on
lines yeah three on page two a
withdrawal Pro uh plan shall be prepared
and it shall provide for the disposition
of property held within the cooperative
and a statement of assumption of
liabilities so this is a recommendation
to say if you can get the votes and it's
an equal vote on both levels between the
whole board and the leaving District so
there's some Equity there that then the
district would be allowed to withdraw
so that's that's the bill representative
luno thank you very much Mr chair
um
I I agree with uh with much of what you
said that um that that I think the
legislature does need to um to provide
some some updated uh policy on how a
pre-existing District would withdraw
from would would withdraw from a co-op
however during the during the hearing on
this bill back in January 27th we
actually didn't hear from
anybody representing a co-op District we
did hear from from a select board member
in Carroll
um uh which uh which is part of SAU 36
but we didn't hear anybody representing
SAU 36 or any other saus at all around
the state uh but but so that that's a
that's a concern but I'm also concerned
as to the the new language in in section
one on page one of the bill which is the
um which is the the Bold language
and not quite sure what's happening with
Roman 1 Roman 2 and Roman 3. when I read
roman 3
which talks about the vote of the entire
Cooperative District
um it I think it differs from what you
said representative Ladd I think it says
that that
the entire corporate
um the majority of Voters voting in
president vote in in the entire
Cooperative District
um
start the withdrawal process or by the
alternative super majority vote under
paragraph two which is only a which is a
three-fifth super majority of Voters
from the
withdrawing pre-existing District not
the full Co-op so it's not an equal
thing either the the co-op could do it
by majority which
um
might make sense but this also appears
to me gives unilateral authority to a
pre-existing District or town who that
wants to withdraw from from a co-op as
long as they get a three-fifths uh vote
of just that
pre-existing District not the full Co-op
District that that I think it may work
in some cases but again without without
having a lot of weigh-in from from from
Co-op districts I I don't know what type
of Jeopardy this would would place on
them I'm also I think confused a little
bit by how Roman 2 is worded
um and um
where it starts off if a three-fifths
majority of Voters present voting blah
blah blah blah blah unless and this is
down the line 26 unless a three-fifth
super majority of Voters present in
voting vote in the negative so it starts
off if voting at three-fifths vote in
the affirmative unless three-fifths vote
in the negative and I'm not quite sure
what's going on with that with that
paragraph but I I would I would however
Mr chair support a motion to retain on
the on this bill
um
and and maybe we get some I mean we we
had we had we had some testimony from
school boards Association
um
that really I think concluded with we
really need a two-year study committee
on on this but I think we really do need
some input from from co-ops before we
plow forward with this uh you know
um it's in our committee I think this is
the place to get it done
I I can respond to that
um I think that you're you're misreading
the bill as as it's written it's yes you
have to have that type of vote amongst
the district that wants to get out of
the co-op but then you're also going to
have the same of course and then they
can send it right to that board and if
in fact the the the town or the co-op as
a whole also supports that you know
um after you've gone through the process
down even sending it down to the school
board state board if it comes back if
you have a three post fifth super
majority of the entire Co-op membership
then that supports the Three-Fifths you
have to have three-fifths on both sides
in the next paragraph it says it
mindset a majority of Voters present and
voting in The Cooperative School
District
or
by the alternative super majority vote
under paragraph two
in paragraph two is a three-fifths super
majority vote of Voters present and
voting in the withdrawing pre-existing
District
and Ted to follow up on that on the the
issue that we need to have more input
we've had dating back to the Jim Grenier
subcommittee which we've had and all the
work we've done in the last session we
know that one out of three District
co-ops are having problems in one shape
form or manner regarding the co-op and
membership in the co-op whether it's
representation on the board or it's
getting out of that or dealing with the
Articles of agreement and we know that
there's some co-ops don't don't even
have articles of agreement yeah Mr chair
I agree with all of that I agree that
co-ops are that that there that there
are issues with that
um and that we need and that right now
there's not a workable solution and that
Co-op agreements seem to be all over the
place
um but I I don't think I don't think
solving it with with something that's
that is is I mean I'm not I'm not
reading it the way you're reading it and
I'm
I mean I don't think solving it with
with with something that could be
misinterpreted or interpreted different
um reflective of what the true intent is
which is a super majority vote of the
Co-op and the super majority vote of the
withdrawing District
um I mean I think if you actually wanted
to have both those things then it would
have easier language than Roman one two
and three in Roman two you you have your
vote in the district that wants to get
out correct
then you have the opportunity to send
that vote directly to the State Board of
Education
or correct if in fact the board as a
whole the all the districts votes on
that same
three-fifths or greater
then that's giving you the signal based
upon this stat story language that you
have the right to withdraw now if you
inform if you do what's also stated in
the on the page two there you have to
deal with all the Property Disposition
then right right and and but before you
even get to the properly Property
Disposition you have to get through
Romans 1 2 and 3 in Roman three uses it
has an or in there which which
you know to me implies that the
pre-existing District would have a
unilateral
um if they if they had a three-fifths
majority vote then it would be a
unilateral decision on the the one
pre-existing tests like that so that you
in in the first uh section that you just
referenced that I discussed that occurs
but you also have the option in that
section to send on your request straight
directly to the State Board where the
State Board acts in accordance with what
the section you're looking at if in fact
the the local Cooperative School
District board the whole
decides that by a three-fifth vote we're
going to let them go it doesn't have to
go to the state board at that point
there's several options or routes which
are available
represent Tanner
sitting over here getting glazed a
little bit
um and wanting to support my Cooperative
School District I would love to see a
side by side almost like
um
a ladder you know a flow chart actually
of what is the present method and what
is this method because some of it's
three-fifths some of its majority vote
it seems like one of this uh one of the
reasons this is like this is if the
withdrawing District wants it gets a
majority vote it circumvents
um the process that's currently in place
and goes directly to this state school
board I mean that's that's what I'm
looking at and I'm just wondering if
you know I I like I said I'd like to see
a side by side and kind of a flow chart
okay here's the withdrawing here's a
district that's
dissatisfied with it um and it goes and
you know this is a a problem not only in
co-ops but I know just in our County uh
Sunapee pays like 50 of the county
budget because they have the highest
property value so I mean it's it's
um
you know it's not a unique to co-ops
um to have this issue it's just with all
and with all the property the rights
that come with dissolving a co-op
um I think it's would be wise to retain
it and like I said I'd like to see for
me to make sense I'd like to see a side
by side with a flow chart okay here's
what happens
further discussion represent Damon
thank you
I just want to note that I find Roman
numeral one and Roman numeral two
it seems to me they sort of contradict
each other so the first Roman numeral
one is talking about majority votes and
then Roman numeral two is talking about
the three-fifth super majority
and otherwise they seem to say the same
thing the way I read it so I find that
remarkably confusing is it a majority
vote or is it a three-fifth super
majority vote which is required
further discussion
represent my way thank you Mr chair I
think
obviously this is an important issue
because it it impacts Carroll County or
Carol more more than just Carol and so
my concern is kind of a piecemeal
approach to this
uh and that notwithstanding Rick your
comments about uh representative
grenier's uh group it would seem to me
that if this would be better to hold it
for further study so that we can begin
to look at this as it relates to not
just Carol but also other other co-ops
that we've had come before us uh and so
I would hope that we we could retain
this bill because I think it's something
that we definitely need to deal with but
I think right now we're really focused
on one Community rather than looking at
all of the other co-ops that are there
that may have a similar kind of an issue
here and that we might be able to come
up then with a standard that would be
applicable uh to all of the co-ops
I can respond to that that
I used Carol as an example of one that's
going on you know or one that's you know
very current but we've had this with
numerous numerous districts within
cooperatives is one out of three uh have
had this type of a problem or and and
there's some others having that problem
right now we're we're basing the payment
per pupil on formulas which just plain
don't work and there are all those
articles of agreement where they have
them and if you're in a small District
within a co-op you basically are have
been had uh you're not going to be able
to change that and it's it's and you can
see it how it's it's ruining this one
that I gave us the example but Connor
Cook's been there there's been others
there as well so uh
it's it's something I feel that we need
to move on if you see something that you
know that you think there's a misread or
something well flush it out but I don't
you've basically got two ways of
withdrawing in one it says if they both
agree you only need a majority
but in two and three it says that
if you have one agree and the other one
and that's why the wording is different
like that
so you need if you have
if they both agree you need a simple
majority done
it only takes one of them
either one of them but you need a super
majority
thank you for that clarification
representative Belcher I think also just
clarify a little further actually it
would take if if the withdrawing party
wanted to leave they can do so against
the wishes of the party with a
three-fifth super majority unless the
other party can muster a three-fifth
super majority stop them I think the
biggest thing we're we're having issues
with is there's a couple missing or
misplaced commas in this there is there
are but also Roman Roman 3 provides the
third option
and I'm online 2829 majority of Voters
present voting there's a misplaced comma
right after at the end of that line in
the entire Cooperative School District
or by the alternative super majority
vote under paragraph two I'm I'm I I
think there's two super majority votes
referred to in paragraph two I think
they're probably talking about the first
one the three-fifth super majority
um voting in favor of with by the
pre-existing District voting in the
affirmative
um yeah have voted in favor of the
withdrawal plan so so Roman 3
gives
unilateral
authority to withdraw to the
pre-existing District by a three-fifths
majority vote
regardless of what the co-op District
vote
that's bigger of the word
um last last week or so we sat here and
discussed uh the village issue uh
overdrawal and Co-op and talked about
how that was distinctly different and at
the time we're on this table we all
concurred all 20 of us uh that clearly
the co-op issues is a problem and we
didn't want to piecemeal it last year
representative cordelli bought a bill to
eliminate all Co-op school with effect
of the July 3 call
this year we bought a piecemeal bill I I
think we I think the decision last week
on The Village was accurate by this
committee and I think the the resolution
or the inference that co-ops are in
danger depending where you happen to be
in the state depending what the value is
and that the entire Co-op piece needs to
be looked as a as a whole and brought
forward to so it can make everyone in
the State uh instead of doing piecemeal
pieces one time he went down there so I
I agree with the the concept of this
bill in terms of we need to provide
other options for calls for this stock
but I don't think we should not keep
piece Milling so we all agree there's
more than one issue in one town I would
much prefer to see a well created a bill
that reviews the entire Co-op situation
disillusionment and then bring that
forward versus piecemeal one at a time
thank you I just like to respond to what
I thought we had clarification on when
we dealt with the Bridgewater issue
that's a unique Village District which
has Municipal Powers with Commissioners
but they're not a school district and
that particular Town also owns their
Elementary School they own it and clear
no debt and so that that is a single and
we had a letter from the attorneys right
here in in uh Concord who indicated that
that is unique it can't be replicated or
duplicated anywhere in this state uh
seeing that the way this was initially
set up was set up by us
by statutory language back in in the
dialogue came up the need of co-op in
general and that's where we all agree
that there's this issue around the state
but you're absolutely correct on on the
village piece 100 and that's why the
committee supported I think and told
yeah representative rep and then
representative forville
yeah I had thought that we had discussed
back when the public hearing was held
that perhaps the way to go would be to
have like a actually committee or
commission to look at the entire thing
and dive into it and have all those
people but was that on a different bill
because I remember having that
discussion we've had the issue and that
the commission study was even we gave we
received a draft copy that from the
school boards Association
um
we've had that thought either committee
or commission
uh on the table here in front of us ever
since we've been talking about
cooperative
we're looking at one issue here there's
other issues that are associated with
Cooperative districts that that
commission would be handling the whole
nine yards from A to Z however this one
we're looking at
how to get out and this has been an
issue which has come up and up and up
and we
I think that this provides a clear
Avenue approach maybe we have the
comments in the wrong place that is more
or less an OLS technical issue that can
be corrected and I don't see this either
as a political issue at all I see this
is uh you know a structure of
organization of providing education in
the state and we need to
um
we need to do something we have a
critical situation in some towns right
now where they cannot afford to continue
going what there are based upon
articles of agreement which were written
back over 50 60 years ago
um so we've got to step in and do
something and the commission study is
going to be another two years or so
before we really uh end up with some
resolution on this representative you
had your hand up
thank you Mr chairman I guess I don't
see this as a piecemeal approach so this
is uh this is an escape Avenue for
members of Cooperative school districts
and it applies to all Cooperative school
districts equally so I I well well maybe
it doesn't address uh all the issues
that Cooperative school districts have
it certainly addresses quite succinctly
an escape mechanism for a community that
no longer wants to be part I I find the
mechanism to be fair and Equitable and
not piecemeal one of the challenges I
think we have is when we when we try to
find solutions for all of the issues
that that a particular organization this
time being cooperative School Districts
The Bill gets so complicated and so
unwieldy that it becomes very difficult
to support
um I I think this has fairly clean
language I think OLS can put the commas
where where they belong and I I think
it's a good and timely Bill thank you Mr
chairman for further discussion
representative cascaden just bringing up
a point when we had that discussion with
Hebron and um
Groton in those other towns we had only
had gotten feedback from one side of the
table and I thought we had said it would
be nice to wait I can't remember if we
retained it or what we did with that
bill did we retain that we passed we
passed it okay but there was a question
at the time of
um you know we really didn't hear much
from the school district or from the
other Selectmen
and and I know you talked about the town
of Carol and I can certainly understand
why they would want to withdraw I mean
this length of time
um but we haven't heard from anybody
else either
and there really isn't
much uh other than
what we see an online testimony but I
think
I think it's time to revise some sort of
a a law for the withdrawal process
because I think more and more towns are
talking about withdrawing but yet the
governor made a point to say he wished
some would consolidate
but people don't tend to go that way for
some reason we we did respond we did
hear from the folks uh by way of the
brief that we got from the school boards
so as uh the State Board of Education
regarding the Carol issue
we had come forward that 413 people
wanted to withdraw 1 306 did not want
that to occur when it breaks down the
town of Carroll was 197 to withdraw with
67 saying no
then Dalton there were 60 saying yes let
them go 208 going the other way don't
let them go then we went to Jefferson 39
said yes they should withdraw 107 he
said no
then you have Lancaster which is one of
your larger out there uh 68 saying yes
let them go 484 saying no
if Wakefield same way 49 saying yes 377
saying no that's where I came up those
total figures so
24.303 said
let them go and so they don't have that
super majority and that what they're
going to have to do is try to get to
that super majority so this bill is not
work designed around them necessarily
it's just designed to provide a format a
process which we as a state would say
this is how you do it so given those
totals how how could this I mean let's
let's run it through
what would happen
well you'd have to first of all do that
197 over the 67 and find out where's
that at three-fifths or not in the town
itself what was the Carol booth
that was it 197 yes
67 saying no you can do the math clearly
of more than two thirds so they've got
it that's right they've got it so and
413 saying yes four one three and then
no one thousand three hundred and six so
so only 20 less than 25 it's less than
that's right it's time
it's 24 24 so if you could run that
through Roman one two and three this
would be a good test case to see what
happens
and I I think you can do that in
mathematics right now yeah but but the
issue being is that this is a process
that you know
um would be a fair process because you'd
have the same amount for both sides
having to get that all right
so so let's let's run it through
um
um you you've got you've got two-thirds
of Carol voting in the affirmative to
vote you've got 25 of the total 24 of
the total Co-op
voting in the affirmative what I say to
withdraw to vote to withdraw so
two-thirds of Carol affirmative to
withdraw
24 of the total Co-op affirmative to
withdraw so going through
Roman one
a majority of the pre-existing District
um
doesn't
apply that's right and then uh and then
uh majority voted uh in the pre-existing
in the affirmative that does apply and
then a majority in the entire
Cooperative in favor of withdrawal that
doesn't apply so Roman one is a fail
correct we're all yeah all right Roman
two three-fifth super majority present
voting in the withdrawing District vote
in the affirmative that applies that's
true
unless a three-fifth super majority of
Voters present voting in the entire
Co-op District vote in the negative
which they did yes so so so they voted
against will so number two fails
Romans 3
a majority of Voters present and voting
vote in favor that fails
or
the super majority vote under paragraph
two voted in favor of the withdrawal
plan that Pat that that
works that passes two two-thirds of
Carol
that vote passes so given those vote
totals
Carol would would be approved to
withdraw okay is that all right
that's how I'm re is that how you're
you look at these eyes pleased over
aren't you yeah I mean
so is that what we want to happen
yes yes yes so so so you so you're in
agreement then that that that a
three-fifth super majority of just the
pre-existing district is all that's
required to withdraw
if uh well no I'm not well but that's
what's Happening Here
welcome Bearer Christina attorney for
thank you chairman lad um good morning
members of the committee thank you for
indulging me
um
I'll talk about the bill specifically
without giving a lot of background just
the interest of time nhsb I think we did
not take a position on this bill
um I hearing the discussion today I
think I I think I either misinterpreted
or misread it or did not clearly
understand the scenarios that you just
went through shows that the two-thirds
super majority for the talents voting
the negative is completely irrelevant if
the town seeking to withdraw gets a
two-third majority vote
three-fifths I'm sorry whatever it was
three-fifths so the so the is the the
language about the other voters in the
town and the remaining towns is
Superfluous it's irrelevant the way the
land and I think we just walked through
the scenarios as well too that the
language about the the super majority of
the towns that are not seeking to
withdraw
is irrelevant given the various with the
three or four scenarios that can that
can happen through this
so I mean I don't
nhsba's position for a while has been as
we talked about the the
um
uh uh the the study commission or what
not over a couple years that's been
alluded to
um you know I don't want to take a a
position specifically on this bill
um you know I I understand the the
concerns have been brought forth to this
committee over the last number of years
I will also say though that there have
been a handful of talented communities
over the last 15 years that have been
able to withdraw from Co-op so it's not
it's not unheard of and it's not
impossible
um
so
I mean is there anything else I can do
to help are there any other questions or
but I as as we walk as we just walk
through those those scenarios the Carol
scenario I think we're all in agreement
correct me if I'm wrong with that the
language about the other towns the other
pre-existing communities that's
irrelevant if if you get a a a
three-fifths super majority in the
represent Belcher
thank you for me I don't actually read
it like that at all if you if you looked
at a paragraph three and it seems pretty
obvious to me that that one comma that
is currently before the word in is
actually supposed to be about six words
down before the word or
yeah that solves the issue here that
makes it very clear that there are two
methods not three to withdraw and that
in the case of Carol in this instance
the three third the two I'm sorry the
super majority against them and the
whole thing would actually prevent them
from being able to leave under this
I think that's a reasonable
so we passing over a misplaced comma is
that's that's the that's the point it
there's an episode of West Wing the toad
TV show where they they there's a in the
in the I believe isn't either the
takings clause or the Commerce Clause
they looked at the original they
couldn't tell if it was a comma or a
smudge of ink that would have changed
the the interpretation of provision of
the Constitution so just as an aside
what's while we're laughing over it
being a comma it has it it has important
the the issue that I see here is that
this is a possible remedy to these
articles of agreement
which co-ops have been fighting now we
just talked about the Bridgewater
situation
one of the discussions in Newfound
school district is to change their
articles around so there's more emphasis
placed on property valuation
the reason why they can't do it is the
agreement they have with Bridgewater if
they change those articles of agreement
without mutual agreement on both sides
Bridgewater is out of that Co-op just
like that bang so they they they're
staying away from that so they're having
and they would love to see that happen
up there in Newfound seeing that you and
I know that Bridgewater is on newfound
Lake and the property valuations are
high
and so I guess where I am is that
because all these articles of agreement
are so very different throughout this
state with different conditions in
how do we as a legislature change those
articles I don't think we can so it's
got to be done either through a
commission study to rewrite this whole
chapter of Law and then we're going to
deal with all the issues which makes it
very very difficult to do and come to
any senses a consensus of agreement or
we try to deal with this particular
singular issue how do you get out and
that's what we're trying to do within
this bill for sure and if I could thank
you chairman if I could comment just to
sort of maybe help the committee there
are a couple different ways that that a
statute could be drafted
to I'm just going to say for lack of
better way of putting this we're making
it easier to withdraw from Cooperative
school district one option you could do
a simple majority vote within the town
looking to withdraw item nhsba does not
think that's necessarily prudent you
could have a a super majority within
that town and the remaining towns have
have no say nhsba does not think that's
proven as well too you could have a
super major you could have a simple
majority in the towns you can withdraw
that could be overruled by a
three-fifths negative in the remaining
towns you could do there I mean you
could do there are different ways that
this could be crafted I thought this you
know initially we thought this bill hit
that but in hearing the conversation
today there still seems to be some
confusion over interpretation and
placement of commas
so if many language were brought forth
would which would change the commas or
the necessary components of this bill to
reflect the intent that I think where
I'm trying to drive at and I hear you
saying the same thing would be something
which would be
so thank you for the question chairman
loud a possible fix for the bill or a
possible fix for co-ops across the state
because a lot of co-ops are a possible
fix for both I mean I just I I don't
want to commit myself to anything
chairman Ladd I hope you recognize and
understand that
um
you know as I initially read the bill
you needed and again I could be wrong if
I as I initially read the bill if you
have a majority Co-op if you have a
majority in the in the town seeking
withdrawal and majority Co-op wide the
withdrawal would go through the other
way I read it was that if you have a
majority
in the pre-existing District seeking to
withdraw that could be overcome by a
three-fifth super majority Co-op wide
that was my initial interpretation of
the bill
foreign
[Laughter]
again very very carefully and basically
there are two methods paragraph one
method and paragraph two method
as
um mayor Christina said
the three part is not another method
it's a if
either one happens or two happens
then this is what this the instructions
what it what has to have you know it's
just the instructions then the state
will do this
it's not another method it's a that this
is what happens if either one or two
passes so as he said in one
it's a majority in two
three-fifths majority of the one unless
there's a three-fifths majority against
of the whole thing
and if either one of those passes that
was the or in there if either one of
those works
then
um it shall issue its certificate to
that effect Etc then we talk about the
process
so three is the process of what happens
if one or two makes it
perhaps I have read dry and then coming
down representative
okay so then thank you Mr thank you
Barrett so that by my reading then Carol
would not be able to not be able to in
three so so my question would be what
does a small District do if they're
always outvoted by three-fifths of the
Cooperative the rest of the Cooperative
right
try to change your articles of agreement
but that still needs the others to go I
I understand that that is part of the
age-old issue at Cooperative school
districts so if you're the small
District in there you're in there
you just screwed that's it
sorry I just what I was going to say
influenced by the previous two speakers
it seems to me that
well I think what uh representative
Lakers just said about number three
being
the next step after one or two happens
may be correct
but we have just spent an extended
period of time discussing what is
clearly quite
uh uncertain to many of us
so this doesn't seem like good
legislation to me if we can't figure
this out what does it say what does it
mean
our Cooperative school districts
supposed to figure it out and how to
proceed
I keep wondering if there's some way to
amend it in a almost instructive step
one step two step three this is what you
do if you want to try to withdraw from a
Cooperative School District
because it's just muddy
to me
let me ask one other question of the
committee then is it worth
getting an amendment today
and moving the calm around or moving a
language around so
this thing works
represent luno Mr chair thanks and I
appreciate the um the the suggestion
there I think there's some very loose
language in here and that may be where
where this goes
um down the road but I would feel much
better if um
if 5 30 had um had more light a day
um from an input from uh from
Cooperative school districts in um in
you know as we craft State policy uh
with respect to withdrawals and I don't
think we need I don't think we
necessarily need to have a have a a
commission to study this but you know if
we were to hold over and work on it this
fall uh I think we could get uh get
something get something done that could
you know pass this committee with a
strong vote and um you know this is
policy that obviously affects I don't
know do co-ops teach more than half the
um students in the state
it's something close to that though I
don't have that information but I know
we have a whole boatload of co-ops what
how many towns within the co-ops total
loss up
yeah for kids so it's about half the
kids so so you know I think if we can
well I'll just respond to that very
quickly I don't want to work on it like
we've done before and then come back and
itl bang you know if we're going to do
that we might as well do it yeah but if
if if we can if we're all in concurrence
here that there is a strong potential
that this can be made right
I'm looking at the time that one appeal
took for Carol from November 2021 to
July 2022 that's just a time working
with the State Board through 15
different meetings
so obviously these school districts are
going through an awful lot of angst and
a lot of difficulty looking for some
kind of resolution to this
and I think it's incumbent upon us to
try to present something which is going
to help them out at least show them
where the bar is
represent leckis
well if this actually doesn't do
anything for Carol and other little
towns like that the way it's written now
then perhaps we should retain it so we
can come up with something that will
help those little towns because this
doesn't seem to this doesn't seem to do
what we wanted it to do
okay what we're going to do right now
we're going to take about a five five
minute caucus we'll have the two groups
go caucus and we'll be coxing in this
room
thank you
foreign
representative Breville thank you Mr
chairman so this bill is enabling
legislation and so it would put the
question to the voters of the school
district whether or not they want to
establish a local education Freedom
accounts and the the question that would
go on the ballot is defined in RSA it
requires a three-fifths super majority
to enable the program there is a safety
net for local school districts the
program can be repealed with a
three-fifths vote so it's very similar
to going from traditional town meeting
to sb2 local form of government there is
a safety net for families in that if a
community chooses to discontinue the the
program the students that are already
enrolled would be able to see that
through uh for the the remainder of
their local education career it sets the
uh it sets the amount of the EFA
based uh it's pegged to the adequacy
Grant from the from the state and in
fact it's set at twice the adequacy
grant so uh under this bill the child
would be counted towards average daily
membership so that the local school
district would still get uh the local
adequacy grant for that child which
would then flow to the child plus a
matching Grant from uh from the local
school district so basically this is
this is putting the question to local
school districts whether or not they
want to allow a specified amount of
money to be able to follow students that
may find
what they perceive to be better
educational opportunities outside of the
further further discussion
represent Cornell
yes thank you I see that there's still
no fiscal note on this do we have any
idea of what this will cost local school
districts
representative reveal do you want to
yeah thank you for the question
representative
um so the the cost per student is
defined uh in in the in the RSA uh if
it's adopted and it would be uh twice
the adequacy grant uh the the adoption
rate
um in any particular School District I I
don't think anybody can predict that
although I would expect it to be a
fairly low adoption rate most people uh
want their children to attend the Local
District school because they want them
to have that sense of of community they
they want to a tie to that Community but
that certainly isn't the best choice uh
for everyone there's further incentives
in that um transportation is guaranteed
in New Hampshire k through eight if you
attend your local District school if you
participate uh in this program then you
lose the benefit of the free public
transportation
um so it's another encouragement
um I I think most people I think most
fam families are quite satisfied with
their local District school so I would
expect that the adoption rate uh would
be would be very low
yes representative Balboni thank you
um just to clarify there's no income
restrictions on this at all and it just
and
um if a student in say my district is
currently attending a private school
and would this money now be available
that my town would have to actually come
up with and pay for our towns portion
for that child to continue to go to the
private school that they're already at
go ahead representative reveal thank you
for the question representative so it's
it's my opinion and I think it's widely
accepted with very few exceptions that
we do not means test public education in
New Hampshire so if we consider the town
that I live in Deerfield New Hampshire
if you move to Deerfield and Rule your
child in in the Deerfield community
school that's our local District school
they do not ask you Mr Mrs burville uh
what's your annual salary so that we can
tell you what uh what amount is going to
be paid by taxpayer dollars and what you
would have to chip in I think that means
testing public education is antithetical
to the to the New Hampshire way and that
is why there are no income caps into
this into this program uh and and yes
there is there is no prohibition uh from
somebody that's currently in
enrolled in a private school to
participate in this this program of
course they would have to go to their
local District school and enroll their
child into the district school to be
able to then Avail themselves of the
program if a community made such a
program available
so the short answer is yes
um
talked about
I know this is punched but it shall be
funded by The Local District and
I perceive this as districts and this is
common still occurs the district schools
have greater property evaluation from
more to their students
and we've been always trying to change
the formula to make something more
disability
to be able to provide a balance
so this is
to me
is an opportunity for those districts
yeah Define smoking versus those that
don't have enough fun as well
so I see it as a little bit biased
um because it goes down that road uh
a local
um
at all the requirements for the adequate
education based on the property taxes
it's a very large community
the neighboring District can do it it
just doesn't seem like it's an
inequitable opportunity
you know they all should be able to get
it through a mistake
or not get by communities because
they're just ads perhaps they're not
surprise representative verville yes
thank you I appreciate I I didn't really
get a question in there but I appreciate
the comments what I would say is that
while we are a Dylan's rule state
we cherish
um local decision making right we we
cherish local control the only local
control our localities can have is the
permissions that we grant them and so is
this program the ideal program for every
school district in in the state
um I don't know I would I would guess
not because there is no one-size-fits
all that is the perfect solution for
every community
one of the most interesting things that
I learned in in the little over six
years that I've been a New Hampshire
State Rep is that we should not let uh
the perfect be the hobgoblin of the of
the good and so I believe that this this
bill allows local communities a little
bit more local control a little bit more
discretion in how they uh choose to
educate their the children of the
community and so for that reason I think
I think the bill is a good bill and I
think it for the communities where it
will work this will be a very good very
good option and for communities where
this doesn't work they simply don't need
to to adopt it
represent Luna thank you very much Mr
chair so you know first of all we know
means test
um uh people going to uh their public
schools because the and it's not just a
it's a New Hampshire way it's the New
Hampshire Constitution the New Hampshire
Constitution says that uh that every
municipality shall provide a um uh it
shall educate it all of its children
through public schools at no cost to um
uh to to those those children or their
families so so you know that's a that's
a little bit different here what we're
doing is we're asking taxpayers
to um to not only you know continue to
fund their local schools but also here
you go here's some five or six grand of
taxpayer money a lot of people that's um
that's you know that's a pretty hefty
chunk of their local property taxpayer
bill but hold on go ahead and take this
and go pay your um your your private
school tuition bill with it so I'm I'm I
think um uh this is certainly going to
be a partisan bill I think it's going to
be great when um when Granite Staters
and voters coming coming up in November
know exactly who is uh voted on the
floor for uh using uh taxpayer dollars
to pay private school tuition bills in
this case it's not taxpayer dollars
coming from business property tax
business Enterprise tax and the
smattering of other taxes that are used
under the current voucher program to pay
those it's people's local property taxes
retirees local property taxes is people
living on fixed income their local
property taxes five six seven eight
grand of their local property taxes
going to pay um someone's private school
tuition bill going any private school
they want so um so a lot of them are you
know maybe going to you know for wealthy
family uh going to um you know Phillips
Exeter Phillips Andover St Paul's any of
these any of these schools and um um and
now they get um
a chunk of change from their retired
next door neighbor I think voters across
New Hampshire are going to love hearing
about this I like to respond to that
um
this bill is not telling any any
District they have to do this or any
taxpayers they have to do this
and when I heard representative Breville
right on Ward one almost he said this is
enabling legislation enabling
and I also heard him speak to local
decision making it's local control so
it's not telling you're going to have to
do this you're gonna have to spend you
know your adequacy money and then and
match it with another dose of money from
you you're you're allowing school
districts to make that decision
themselves
if they don't like that idea they don't
do it but what we are doing excuse me I
I'm speaking right now
the the rationale behind this is that we
want the local decision making at the
local level we want to have the
opportunity for a local school board to
make the decision what is the best
Fit For A Child whether it be in their
local education public school program
which probably the vast vast majority
would say yes that's where I'm going to
and that was also mentioned by
representative reveal that there's a lot
of good social experiences and all to be
experienced by being in with the public
school with your community with your
neighbors Etc but there are some
situations that perhaps that's not the
best fit and so once again this is a
decision that's made locally at that
local board or Community says no we're
not going to do this then you don't do
it it's that simple representative
Belcher
thank you Mr I just wanted to follow up
on something because I had a small
question because I am obviously first
year in the education committee I'm
aware of some of the Court findings that
have impacted the way we do things but I
heard a quote that the New Hampshire
Constitution says that we shall fully
fund education strictly through public
schools in New Hampshire
um prep luno can you tell me where I
would find that at the New Hampshire
Constitution
thank you
through
well until represent Luna finds a
represent cascadden just a question for
this group why why is there cherishing
local control for issues like this
but yet there's you want state
government control for the issues and
curriculum and instruction that belong
because this involves local Monies
and the other involves State monies and
so local control for things that only
the locals are paying for and State
control for the things that the state is
reps and luno
so
um so the the Supreme Court in Claremont
uh quoted in the quotes in their
decision quote we hold it part two
article 83 imposes a duty on the state
to provide a constitutionally adequate
education to every educatable child
educable child in the public schools in
New Hampshire and to guarantee adequate
funding that was Supreme Court decision
Claremont B Governor
thank you for that um and I assume that
was the PO that was the where they were
pointing to the New Hampshire
Constitution where the Constitution
actually says we shall cherish education
but it doesn't actually say in the
Constitution that we shall only fund
public education or rather Public
further further discussion
representative paternal thank you Mr
chair
um I think I heard that every
municipality shall provide an adequate
education for the students
but as a homeschooler
one of the
um
struggles that I heard most often from
families
who were trying to figure out what to do
with their students who are struggling
in school
was that
especially in our community their only
option was maybe to homeschool and that
because there just isn't another place
locally to send their children
and
what I was hearing from those parents is
that
there's their children were not being
provided adequate education for their
needs and they may not have fit into
special education profiles needing an
IEP or a 504. but they would have
been happier for their students their
students would have succeeded more had
they had an option like this and this
lick leaves
local control in place because the towns
have to vote first they have to decide
and you need I mean 25 people
it just it leaves it all in the hands of
the local voters and is doing what is
best for the parents and the students
representative Breville
thank you Mr chairman so
it it's interesting that when we talk
about making money available to follow a
child
that we quickly Chase to oh my goodness
we're subsidizing the rich
do you know who already has freedom of
school choice
in our society
those that are well off those that come
forward to pay their local property tax
to fund their local District school and
then also be able to afford to send
their child or children to a private
school of their choice
do you know who doesn't have that option
people of marginal means
people that don't make enough money to
be able to do that
what I've heard for a long time as a
citizen in New Hampshire
is it the adequacy grant
is inadequate
and that's a debate for another day
but if I take it on its face and I
concede the point and say correct the
adequacy grant is insufficient
then perhaps you have to Benchmark the
amount to something
so twice the adequacy imagine a family
of marginal means
having access to twice the adequacy
grant to be able to educate their
children
that's who would benefit from this
program if a local District chose to
enable it those are the real
beneficiaries the people of of high
means
already have the money to be able to do
those things it's people of moderate
means that don't have access to it and
and the state EFA is a first great good
fight at the Apple to get there right
and it's funny because at one time I
hear
the adequacy grant is wholly
insufficient to adequately educate a
child
but then when I double the amount all of
a sudden I hear oh my goodness we're
just going to throw buckets of gold at
at Rich families and and I don't think
that that's correct this is a good faith
effort
to help the marginalized families
financially marginalized families and
students in this state to be able to get
a good education and I'll tell you what
if if double the adequacy grant allows a
poor child with financial aid from
Phillips Exeter Phillips Andover or any
other private school
to get the the education of their dreams
the education that best fits their needs
then I am all for that I am absolutely
all for that and it's hard to imagine
somebody would be against it
so
if we put it if we if we cap it if we
put a a an economy an income cap
right that's when we start pitting those
that have against those that have not
and where do you draw the line there's
always that family
that is just over where you set the cap
and they can't afford to do it on their
own and they don't have access to the
program because they're just above the
cap this is a great bill I look forward
to the house floor debate I look forward
to the roll call and I'm I'm glad that
that my partners on the other side of
the aisle are going to gonna participate
in that debate and participate in that
roll call so that we can decide what we
want to do here thank you Mr chairman
thank you for the discussion
representative Brian
thank you Mr chairman
um in in my town
we were statutorily allowed to give a
tax break to the local private high
school
that is in town can be Union Academy by
um uh not taxing their dormitories and
um
dining Halls
there was a fund in Plainfield for high
school students who got into KOA by
passing their exam to divvy up to use
for tuition it saved Our Town a ton of
money because we didn't have to pay
tuition fees for those students to go to
Lebanon High School so for a town that
you know has an area agreement or um
pays tuition to a high school this is an
option to save some money and provide a
really good opportunity that didn't
exist before
what we did in town was voted on it
every year whether we wanted to do it or
not and we had a study committee
appointed by the moderator who studied
the benefits and the non-benefits of the
program every year to in order to
present something at town meeting it was
under a microscope the whole time and it
lasted for a long long time I'm hoping
that a local District would would adopt
similar things if they adopted these
programs I guess
um my question to you as writing the
bill is uh what
happens when there are many scholarships
right now we have one scholarship
organization that monitors the efas but
there's a possibility that many
different ones could be approved perhaps
so you would have Choice which one to to
go ahead thank you Mr chairman yeah so
much of the language that's in this bill
mirror is the language that's in our
existing uh State EFA program uh to make
the the management of the programs that
much easier
um the state EFA allows for more than
one scholarship organization should
another choose to enter the space and
and this bill would certainly track with
that and and allow for more than one
scholarship organization to be able to
manage uh these accounts to enter into
the space
yes so each family would be able to
choose which scholarship Association or
would a town all go with one
organization
may I guess go ahead thank you for the
question
um it it's my understanding uh that the
family would would be able to choose
that organization that they would be
contracting with that organization to to
manage those to manage those funds
further discussion represent cascadden
um not really a question but just want
to clarify the representatives
point on choice and the timing of
everything
a parent has always had the choice of
how and where to educate their children
the dispute comes because now we are
asking for local property taxes to
provide that education so I just want to
be clear about that I didn't come from a
wealthy family but my parents long
before you were born made the decision
to send me to private school
like many others so parents have a
choice they've had a choice make that
choice
but it comes at a time where now we're
tapping public funds
representative
thank you Mr chairman and I appreciate
that and please know I I'm the product
of public education I went through
grades one through eight in in Pembroke
where I grew up I went to Bishop Brady
High School my parents chose to send me
there I went to Plymouth state for my
undergrad and I'm a grad school dropout
out of out of two lanes so I've I've
been in a lot of those things I'm a
former High School science teacher I get
it
when you say families have the choice
not all families have the choice there
are a lot of families that simply don't
have the financial means
to choose any other option other than
their local District school
this bill
and I I don't deny
my proclivity
that we don't means test public
education so the question is how do we
Define public education right so this
bill
adopts my view of public education which
is the educating of children of a
community using Community funds taxpayer
dollars
there is a different school of thought
right that says that the taxpayer
dollars all have to go
to a local District school
and that's the that's the only path
for the vast majority of children
but there's Exceptions there too right
the most needy
special ed students
get out of District placement
to go to special schools that can
appropriately meet their needs
and the vast majority of them
are private institutions
we have communities that don't have a
school the district school of certain
grades in their community and so they
tuition their kids to other non-public
schools it's being done right this is
this is simply an expansion of those
types of opportunities
to to a community if they choose to do
that and when we say we don't we don't
let tax dollars flow to private schools
that you know that that's not it's not
correct at the at the K through 12 in
New Hampshire there's certainly
exceptions to that right it's certainly
not true once we talk about secondary
education right you take your Pell Grant
you can take your federally subsidized
student loan and go to any school you
want private school religious school
wherever you wherever you're lucky
enough to get to get accepted
so I I understand the pause of making
this tax quote-unquote taxpayer money
available to families that already have
the means to support a district school
and a private school
and I get that it's kind of a rub but
but that's fair and Equitable that
everybody has the same access to the
same opportunities with the local money
and that's why I didn't put means
testing into this bill and that's why I
would oppose a a motion to to do that
this this bill really is designed and
intended for the families that don't
have the means that would like to make
another choice
further discussion representative Tanner
thank you I and this is just a comment
because that's what we're in we're not
in a question and answer period
um with public money goes accountability
and my whole issue
has been that the EFA and the children's
scholarship fund with that money there
isn't the accountability
there is discrimination that's going on
that that's against our
non-discrimination laws in the state
and we don't we don't as taxpayers
have
the feedback and the oversight that we
should have on how our money is being
spent
nor a cap on how much money is being
so um I can't vote for this bill
and that's my state
I'm glad the issue of accountability
came up because uh we need a little bit
more of that in the public education
don't we if you look at the achievement
scores which we have and if
accountability we're going to talk about
that we have the same type of
accountability for you know everybody in
the state one test the state test well
that is that's not a good measure of
student uh performance or growth it may
give us some data but it does not
necessarily really speak to the holes
and the strengths of a student
if we did something more Diagnostic in
nature it might help but so what we're
just doing we're complying with federal
law that's all we're doing so we can get
the confederal
uh it doesn't mean we're holding anybody
accountable certainly because that's not
reflective of where we've been with our
scores over the last decade
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
follow up because we just heard that
there may be some discrimination going
on in some of the current programs I
abhor the concept of discrimination hate
it don't like it anywhere
and I would ask if I can give one or two
examples recitations I would love to dig
into it and what I can find I will help
try to solve anything I can
further discussion represent miler well
we've really opened up a box of worms
here haven't we yes we have first of all
there is accountability
there's an elected countability
you have school boards that are elected
you've got school district meetings that
hold and uh
deal with budgets there's accountability
there if I send a check to a private
school I've got no accountability there
um and um
I forgot
Mr Belcher representative Belcher what
did you just say please because I want
to respond oh discrimination yes
yes well documented
if I've got an lbgq child who I want to
have a Christian education
won't let me in there
we've had we've had in this committee We
Have Heard
stories not stories but facts of a child
who was in Dover who was in a Christian
School
was about who was on track to be a
valedictorian and in this in his Junior
Summer going into a senior year
basically came out and said he was gay
guess what happened to him
he was not admitted next year he was
excluded because he happened to be an
lbgq students so don't tell me that
there's not discrimination as it relates
to the application of these Monies
one area of accountability we haven't
talked about and I think it's the
greatest accountability is the parent
when
when you make the choice the decision
where you which what the child's going
to do it's going to be the parent
working
and deciding what is the best situation
for my child and that's what we're
talking about the the parent knows that
child best
and I I think that we can't lose sight
of that so when we talk accountability
we need to also be talked about the
prime accountability individual and
that's the parent
represent leckis
there's also the accountability of how
the money is spent and we really don't
have a lot of accountability when it
comes to public schools and when it
comes to efas every penny every penny
has to be okayed that it is actually for
an educational purpose or that money
doesn't go out so there's extreme
accountability as far as that goes
and they still have to put an annual
report in just like your public school
does they still have their annual report
represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair and um you
know I'll I'll be honest I'm pretty
disappointed in this committee's um
position when uh when it comes down to
uh Public School accountability as we
voted uh 10 10 no recommendation on
House Bill 371 last week which would
have established a legislative oversight
Commission on the um the the minimum
standards for public schools which are
undergoing a unilateral
back room locked closet
um uh a rewrite the first draft of that
actually finally came out I think last
week uh just moments before the um
the um the draft went to the State Board
of Education so so the vote out in this
committee was along party lines with uh
with all Democrats thinking it makes a
lot of sense to have a um uh a
legislative oversight committee on the
minimum standards for school approval
and all Republicans on the committee
voting against it so um so let's let's
when we talked to the talk let's walk
the walk and um and that's that's that's
my my line on public school
accountability and what what you've seen
come out of this committee
I'm going to respond to that also
because that that's really not what the
we talked about at that on the committee
we do have in place the legislative
oversight committee and a meeting has
been established to look at these
standards in fact the standards were
brought up by the Legislative oversight
committee prior to
going back three or four months and now
we have another one yes we have received
the minimum standards for public school
approval and immediately we have now
that meeting set up if we had gone the
route that you were asking for that that
particular commission committee wouldn't
even be on board until September
and we're losing mileage there so the
legislative oversight committee which is
tasked with a responsibility for looking
at academic standards academic state
that we put in well you can't tell me
that academic standards are not part of
the uh Public School the minimum
standards of public school approval they
are different but they also are linked
and they're both approved by the State
Board of Education so you know the
intent and what they now if if that's
where where you are we won't discuss
those things that the legislative
oversight committee if that's what you
want
we won't do it
we'll just deal with academic standards
but I don't think that's appropriate I
think it's appropriate we look at both
and and uh to assess those to determine
that those standards are reflective of
the granite state that are reflective of
the needs we have the effective
reflective of what we the standards we
would want to put in place for the
approval of schools in this state so I I
you know I disagree I think we're
talking process more we are that the
basic principles and concepts of the
whole thing we do have a good process in
place we don't need more committees and
more commissions we need the commissions
and the Committees we have doing their
jobs and and uh without having to
develop another Mega commission that has
more people on it that we have letters a
represent Myler call the question yeah
is there any further discussion on this
on this question I agree we need to call
it
Madam clerk we're on four third five
chairman Ladd yes
the representative Virgo yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative Corey Taylor yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Ellison no representative Woodcock
representative Hall no representative
Balboni no Representative cascadden no
representative Damon no 10 years 10 days
oh who will be writing the uh itl
Premiere motion please
I'd like to make a motion itl
okay yeah I was already assuming we were
there and I apologize okay
representative
and second by representative luno Madam
clerk do you have that it all motion
chairman Ladd
no
representative Ravel no Representative
no representative Ford no representative
Belcher no representative try no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
pedernal no Representative
no representative Myler yes
yes representative lunao yes
representative Ellison yeah
representative yeah representative Paul
yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
10 years 10 days
okay
alrighty uh we are at about eight
minutes of noon hour right now
um we can go into
upcoming uh we do have an amendment for
uh
539 and we need to pick that up uh for
the you you've got it there
um would you please pass that Amendment
out so everybody have a ability to look
at that Amendment over the lunch break
of what it basically does it changes
that bill from you know that's the one
where two hours before and two hours
after it changes it to one hour
yeah one hour prior one hour afterwards
I believe and
and are there see is there an amendment
for 572
representative Ellison
okay is that passed out to everybody so
if we can get that passed out to
everybody as well
on 573 okay limiting EFA funding
do you have that one available uh
okay
it doesn't look like we have any snow
coming down out there so we're going to
take our usual hour break
and we will start promptly at
come on
foreign
45 that way we give you a few minutes to
slop around
here's another
570. 572 wait a minute
okay last week I got that and then yeah
okay okay let's just take that break and
and of course
yeah yeah to do that it's just not in
its charge so it's it's going to be in
its charge
you heard me many times talks about the
difference between academic and minimum
absolutely and I I feel it's a real
closeful relationship and that's what
that's why I wrote up three three I I I
I got that I was just looking at
timeliness I think we need it right on
and I went I don't I don't know if
you've gone through that trash copy I
have I have to I got blue sticky notes
yeah we we will do it then because I I
do have some sheets I've been looking at
okay if I could start and do a speech on
something that's perhaps a little less
okay you'll probably do the speech and
foreign
we're going to set some rules up here
for the
the latter part on some of these bills
where we're going to try to limit the
number of speakers
so we can do it like we did the last day
in the afternoon there where we had one
speaker for each party
that might be a great idea to try to get
on board with again
so
um
if we get by a certain hour here you
know
my exhaustion hour
which might be about 2 30. we might have
a one-on-one type discussion then vote
okay so let's start out right now
I'm going to keep marching right down
where we were I'm not going to go back
to the top I'm going to do 539 first
539 deals for vaccination clinics in
schools
and I call upon represent
Belcher for a motion
thank you Mr chair I would move ought to
pass is there a second
second represent Ford Sacrament so it's
made by Belcher second by Ford
represent Belcher uh do you would you
like to speak your motion yes and uh
shall I introduce the amendment that I
have now or should I wait on that no you
should go ahead and introduce your
excellent I would like to introduce uh
rep cordelli's Amendment
2023-0706h very small Amendment um it
changes the timeline on the original
bill for which uh these vaccination
clinics would be prohibited schools
from the original two-hour timeline down
to a one hour timeline this is done in
order to provide schools with more
latitude and ability to conduct vaccine
clinics on their location while still
allowing students that are not to be
partaking time to make sure that they're
no longer just kind of hanging around
school and accidentally possibly get
um as to the underlying Bill itself we
heard a fair bit of testimony on this
bill and we heard
um and we saw a documentation that at
least two New Hampshire students were
vaccinated without consent in New
Hampshire in recent time and one
explicitly against parent wishes we even
saw the documentation that said do not
vaccinate but they received it anyway
and then we went on to hear also from if
I'm not mistaken the Department of
Health and Human Services
that these vaccine clinics are something
that we conduct under Federal auspices
in order to satisfy our requirements as
a state for certification in various
mass casualty and bio Warfare
certifications
um
we do these things in order to
um rather we don't obviously we do the
vaccinate the students but we also at
the same time do them to check that
Federal box
and I'm going to go on record here and
saying that we when we obviously have
shown the inability
to have zero errors in a program like
this should not be complicating Matters
by trying to
double up our efforts to check Federal
boxes and do all these other things
while we're also vaccinating children
because that seems like it's going to
add complications and more problems to
this sort of thing beyond that it's um a
lot of parents came to me a lot of
parents sent me emails they said they
are uncomfortable a lot of them have
said they've held their children out of
school on days when they've heard these
things may be going on because they're
afraid they may accidentally get swept
up in these programs now this isn't some
anti-vaxxer nonsense I don't think
anybody here doesn't want children to
get the vaccines they need to get so
long as they have parental informed
consent that's not what this is about
it's just about being safe and making
sure we're not accidentally
giving children vaccines that they have
not received affirmative and informed
consent from their parents for thanks
further discussion
represent Ford used second the motion do
further discussion from the committee
yes representative Cornell so I'd just
like to quote someone from the last bill
that we were talking about that said we
cherish local control and I think this
is a local decision that's that's best
met that would that the just local
Local District can decide what best
meets the needs of their Community you
know there are you can say an hour but
students that go home on a bus whose
parents don't have a car don't have
means of transportation aren't going to
be able to get them back to school to
get that vaccination so I I think it I
think it's horrible that two people two
children were vaccinated by mistake and
I think that there can be more controls
put in to make sure that that never
happens again but I I think that if if
Manchester wants you decide to have
vaccine clinics at the schools that
should be a Manchester decision and I
don't think there should be the rest of
the state should be making that decision
for them
for the discussion
not seeing any Madam clerk would you
and so yes on the amendment zero seven
zero six h
B 539
dealing with vaccinations in schools
Mr chair yes could we do Amendment votes
by hand
just to move this along
it's up to the the clerk over here is
that okay can you count up to ten okay I
don't know after this morning I'm not
sure
all those in favor of adopting the
amendment raise your hand
S three
and all those opposed
okay Ted
ten yeah
okay uh represent Belcher you're
recognized for our emotion
uh thank you Mr I believe the motion on
and I would I would just add that this
bill remains a very good bill even
without the amendment the idea is to
make sure children don't get swept up to
these vaccine clinics one or two hours
okay any further discussion
yes
um I agree with representative belka
except for this is a DHHS issue this is
an implication of the show it had
nothing to do with the school holding it
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll
chairman Ladd yes
representative verbal yes representative
leckis yes representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Peter now yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Myler
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Ellison representative
Wilcox representative Hall no
representative Balboni no Representative
cascadden no representative Damon no
attendee 10 years 10 days
representative
Cornell
I move
represent Meyer seconds it
further discussion
now I'm clear
chairman Ladd
yes
oh excuse me uh what yeah no no no no no
no no no no no no too late
no
Representative erville no representative
like us no representative Ford no
representative Belcher no representative
Drive no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
petternell no
Representative cortiello no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yeah representative woodcut
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
10 years 10 days okay represent Cornell
you're going to write the report on itl
um
and Reps yeah represent voucher doing
the OTP
um a
um these reports now we're getting
crowded uh so I would really appreciate
it I'm going to be giving Lindsay the
reports because I got about 20 20 so of
them that I'm for the seventh and the
eighth now we're on the 13th here these
have to be done
I'd like to see them into me this by
this evening sometime if you could send
it on that template which we have
that way I can put them all in a folder
and get all three days to Lindsay
tomorrow morning for a work on or on
Wednesday morning if we're if we're shut
down tomorrow I've just heard then she's
gonna have to do this on Wednesday along
with the bills that we are on Thursday
morning that we do on Wednesday so it's
going to be we really need to try to
help her
so please get these to me by this
evening
I usually go to bed around midnight
so on this on this stuff so yeah
Clark Smith has already sent out an
email that tomorrow is canceling point
tomorrow let's rescheduled to Wednesday
yeah okay so that means she's going to
be doing all this on Wednesday so let's
try to help her out by getting so I can
get this stuff to her so I can work on
it get in the folders and chase people
because I just got all the reports for
the 7th and the 8th
Sunday night
so it takes a while to do the chasing
here
the next one which I I'd like to address
is the going back and get this 331 done
uh this is the bill which has the it's
an EFA bill it's representative lectus's
she's the prime sponsor of it has no cap
on the amount of money for eligibility
it's from
this comes from the prior Friday
I Look to
representative uh Belcher for our motion
please
or reps and Lexus okay yes it is yours I
move to retain this the HB 331
is there a second second
so we have a motion on the table to
retain
331 made by represent leckis and second
by paternal
representative leckis
yes I opted to retain because we know
that this will otherwise end up with a
10 10 and we will waste lots of time on
the floor arguing over it in this way
representative parental do you have any
further discussion no
open to the rest of the committee for
discussion
yes reps on luno yeah thank you very
much so I think I'm going to vote
against the the
um retaining this because I don't
believe
raising the income threshold is
something that um that that you know
expansion of the program is um
is is warranted right now particularly
that um that that the program hasn't
even been subject to I think the
performance audit that's coming up this
fall so so I'm going to vote against the
um the retain and and um and you know
move itl after this
further discussion
chairman lad
yes
representative burville yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald
yes
representative Noble yes representative
yes representative cortiello yes
representative Miler representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative Luna no representative
Ellison no representative
representative Hall Nell representative
Balboni no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon
recognized for a motion I move OTP on
331.
is there a second
second
same second representative paranel
and discussion
I think at this point we all know all
further from the second
any comments don't any further uh
now clerk we have a motion of OTP
for the bill um 331
chairman lad
yes representative verbal yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative courtiero yes
representative Myler
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner nope representative Luna no
representative Ellison oh representative
Wilcox representative Hall no
Representative no Representative no
representative Damon
no
10 years 10 days
Mr chair I'll move on I'll move itl
thank you is there a second
made by representative Miler so
represent luno makes the motion and
representative mower seconds it the
motion is itl on 331.
when you're ready Madam Clerk
chairman lad no
representative Orville no Representative
lekkas no representative Ford
no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Peter no no
Representative no representative Miler
yeah representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative yes representative Hall
yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes 10 years 10
days thank you very much
the the reports are going to be written
by representative leckis
and for the OTP and the itl on this no
recommendations represent luno
72 excuse me
relative to eligibility for free School
meals
let's see I'm looking for a motion here
um
[Music]
represent Belcher you would like to make
I suppose I can
um
oh second motion made by representative
Belcher second by reps and leckers itl
on on the five 572 referencing School
discussion thank you Mr chair I I think
there's a couple significant issues that
come up with this bill the first of
which being that the federal guidelines
for reimbursement in this program are
set at I believe 185 percent we're
easing at the 300 percent we put the
rest of that burden on the uh New
Hampshire taxpayers directly and in
particular it calls for drawing this
from the education trust fund which is
another strain on public education
dollars that we've heard so much about
recently
um another issue that it brings up is
that it would require Stu schools that
do not currently participate in this
Federal program to do so which some
schools have other options that they are
currently attending to and I don't think
it's necessary for us to be um
attempting to override that when they
already have something in place
thank you
representative Riley
the committee has before a proposed
amendment
and would it be appropriate for
representative Allison to at least
review the amendment or representative
Hall to review the amendment so at least
we know what the parameters are of the
conversation here sure I have no
objection to that representative Allison
thank you Mr chair uh the amendment does
just two things uh one is that it
specifies the uh specific source of
funds that would be used to pay for the
additional meals and two it changes the
effective date from July 1 or 60 days
after that much in that to September 1st
of 23. uh that's basically those are the
two changes on the amendment uh in terms
of the the bill itself uh we've gone
over and over and over this uh we feel
strongly that one of the best one of the
things that needs to be done is that
hungry kids in New Hampshire who go to
school need to be fed
and that is a responsibility on this
side uh that we we feel strongly about
in terms of the uh 300 percent which is
the bill raises uh
the eligibility to 300 percent of of
poverty
300 seems to be a a common
number here in terms of lots of bills
that 300 percent uh we move people up
because they need to have some
assistance and we've been doing that uh
so we're right that 300 percent is right
in line with what the committee's been
going forward with uh having said that
uh I would I'm sure that we would not
object to uh
the committee if they wanted to move it
to 350 percent as we have looked for
were redone we we'd have no objection on
this side in terms of uh moving at the
350 percent
uh this is uh
this is a very very very important issue
it it is involved with
what we provide to our kids and we've
gone over debate after debate after
debate about what happens in school when
kids are hungry how they can't learn uh
how their their grade point average is
drop uh they have more discipline
problems I don't think the research on
this is is is is really uh disputable
some people might want to do that but I
doubt it very much to have a discussion
over whether hungry kids learn better
than than kids who are offender the
other way around uh so we're more that's
the essence of the amendment uh and
pretty much it's pretty much encompasses
the bill as well
thank you uh represent Hall
thank you Mr chair
um recently in the online I wrote a
quote from a member of this committee
who said and included myself that some
of the folks on this committee do not
support kids
and I took that personally and I thought
I've supported kids my whole life
and food insecurity doesn't exist in
isolation
we you know talk about the cost of
housing utilities Transportation this is
putting tremendous stress on families so
if you really care about kids we want
kids to go to school and School meals
are important as representative Ellison
said childhood hunger should not be it
should be a non-issue in New Hampshire
so I would say this should not be uh it
should be bipartisan we should be
supporting kids feeding them so that
they can learn
further discussion
remember we're discussing the the motion
is itl we have this amendment that we're
just talking about right
if we don't feed the kids you
if we don't feed the kids and then we
assess the kids what we have is garbage
for data
you don't fail to feed the football team
and then complain because they lose the
games
you can't do that it's not fair it's not
logical
if you want people to perform at their
best you can't ask them to do it when
they're hungry
it just doesn't make sense
you say oh the parents are supposed to
do it I'm not here to talk about what
parents should or shouldn't do and this
bill won't correct that
and that's why I support it
I support it because it helps us
accomplish what we're ostensibly setting
out to do is it the perfect solution no
it may be a necessary solution until we
achieve that whatever state it is where
the parents can do it
I don't think the parents myself being a
parent having sent kids to school I
don't think they choose not to feed
their kids
but for whatever reasons they can't
don't whatever
and in that case I think if we want to
have a school system and we want the
data we collect about the performance of
that system in which we invest quite a
then we ought to at least make it so the
measurement is Meaningful
because it's very easy to invalidate as
soon as you say the kids are starving
well that's overstaying it but they're
hungry
represent Luna
oh represent mileage did you have your
hand all of a sudden
okay I I do have a concern um the
federal government says it's 185 for the
free and reduced and 130 for the free
why is it that the federal government
hasn't upped the ante in terms of their
responsibility
and moved it up to that 300 when you
talk about 300 for other programs those
are State programs this is a federal
program and we are seeing reimbursement
at 185.
um
so uh are we now going to say the
state's going to have to cough in and
and and and pay for what the federal
maybe should be doing
I don't know
so I I guess my concerns rest with that
we're not getting the funding support
for a program which basically is a
federally reimbursed program
we want to go to 300 perhaps the federal
government should go 300. further
discussion
yes representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair I won't belabor this
very long but I just to get to the heart
of this we're dealing with a little bit
of an ethical issue here who has a
responsibility to feed children and if
we were just speaking for myself if we
were just talking about a doing a state
program here and wanting to feed kids
that would be a lot easier to get me on
board than expanding and solidifying our
participation in a federal program that
comes with Federal strings and federal
requirements so if if in the future
somebody wants to introduce a bill that
moves us toward a new hampshire-based
model
I'd like to talk to you about that but
I'm not interested in this Federal stuff
represent woodcock
thank you and um Cheryl I was going to
wait not speak but I have to speak
um
first thing I I Mike has a point but the
the reality is the federal money if you
we just bypass it we don't get any money
for zero to 130 so that's I mean that's
millions of dollars are giving away
I would suggest that this is this bill
is probably one of the most
transformative bills we've had in the
six years I've been here efas efas is a
transformative bill
you folks who supported that when you
walk away from this whenever you're done
you can say wow that's what I do for
Education this is exactly the same thing
except this transformed into 160 000
kids population in the school this
community this state
this summer Oliver excuse me brother
though Ford and Lucas and I and Mullen
and Paul and Allison sat for hours and
in the fall listening to the Heart
Association doing Hampshire Solutions 68
hours of hunger all kinds of anecdotal
information over and over again this is
not a interim study committee that met
for a half an hour had a beer went home
these people worked and looked at dad
and looked at that and looked at data
there is no question about that I sat on
a delegation it was representative
personal and Belcher and Cordelia myself
voted for a gift to a local wolfborough
for five thousand dollars for 58 hours
of hunger everyone voted yes no one
asked of a limited income who needed who
did it we knew the kids needed the food
you just can't back off on that uh and
so I want to make sure earlier Robinson
Cordell is not here unfortunately but I
will mention him we're going to stay
downstairs last week it's about the
children it's about the children hell
he's banging his hand it's about the
children that's the best what this is
exactly what this is about the children
us older people not the younger ones Mr
President McDonald may have never heard
of Demi but all of us been involved with
tqm have heard of Deming and it says he
says one of the things that tqm is the
responsibility of the community well
this is the responsibility Community the
educational Community if you believe in
what we're doing this is the
responsibility of the education
community
I heard the representative talk about
families of marginalized need these are
families the Modern Life need when we
look at the covid money that came down
and when they fed youngsters across the
district everyone and now we talk to
those schools who are the kids that
aren't getting fed so give them my July
needs of no income or lower who are out
of that Gap that's who Mike getting said
those folks are struggling the zero
three hundred and zero 185 are getting
that
so yeah we do need this it's going to be
if you pass the amendment I'm switching
against the IPL but basically all the
same information you pass the amendment
after the member representative
Ellison's Amendment talks about putting
this educational trust fund because this
is one of the most critical things we've
done here this is transformational this
is the buck what we do this is the
Baseline so I asked if you vote against
the itl vote for the OTP a is revenue
Ford did and stand up one time for our
New Hampshire kids give them the
Baseline it's hell of the hungry they'd
have no place to sleep they can't eat
they're not going anywhere I don't care
what test you put in front of them what
book what person what math the matter is
not going to matter
thank you president-eleven thank you
I'm going to ask what happened when the
federal government when we put idea into
place and they said we're going to give
you 40 of the cause
we're down to 16 now who's paying that
other difference now
um see I I I understand the the the the
intent of this bill and I understand
that there are certain responsibilities
which parents do have themselves
for their children
um but I don't understand why the state
is going to say well we're gonna we're
gonna now pick up something that's
really part of this Federal program and
uh I then you have run into the issue of
well okay now which of these students
now it's going to be more administrative
costs figure out which one to comply
with 185 or less so that we can get the
federal component there but the ones
which are 186 or more uh we're gonna
have to break that out and pay fully for
that that's how I see it because there's
going to be some reimbursement for part
we're still we still go to the 186 and
Below we know that and and I agree with
you that the idea how about special
education money I agree there the
extended.com they have it what about
retire in our state the state was going
to the state was going to help every
local town and they didn't
all right so I mean everybody backs off
but the reason we're going to do this we
should do this because this New
Hampshire kids New Hampshire money and
we have responsibility
and I don't care if the federal
government's not paying Ida as regards
to this matter
thank you representative Damon
I think this is an extremely important
and also extremely cost effective build
what School meals provide in the
nutrition composition for what they cost
is actually pretty amazing
they're not perfect but they're very
very good in
the amount of protein the amount of
nutrients the ability to help the brain
work better
one of the landmark pieces of research
in my field as a dietitian is the Iowa
breakfast study which was done in 1949
and it's been
reiterated and re-assessed
countless times over those decades
and concisely put it very very clearly
showed that people who are fed breakfast
have much better intellectual capacity
cognitive function mid to late morning
and through the day than people who are
not fed
honestly I think this is a no-brainer I
do not understand why we wouldn't feed
the kids representative Breville
thank you Mr chairman
so I I don't necessarily disagree with
you
but I also get hung up
because on the federal program
you have to take the balanced meal you
have to take it all you don't like the
green beans get the green beans and the
green beans come up in the trash right
maybe it's not really whatever the food
item is right so when you're forcing
children because that's what the federal
program does because it it wants you to
have the balanced meal in a lot of
school districts it has greatly
increased the solid waste costs because
of food that's getting thrown into the
barrel because that's not what kids want
for breakfast
I am fully on board
with feeding kids the problem with the
federal programs are the it's a top-down
one-size-fits-all type of model that has
a lot of flaws and for that reason I
would go uh with the upper the other
representative and say if if we want to
do this for New Hampshire kids
and and it's it's a lot of cause it
should be a New Hampshire program so
that we squeeze waste out of the system
because right now the way a system is
designed where we're generating food
waste so kids can can pick the little
bit that they want and and for me that
that's a high burden
that's awesome
sure
so
Federal School meals program
s have been revised a number of times
over the years and to be frank with
respect
I'm not sure you're completely up to
date on what's served there's actually a
lot more flexibility in it now than
there used to be
and in schools where kids do
a waste Assessment program the kids
collect and Whey and tally and do it as
a science and math experiment what's
happening with the amount of waste from
their School meals
the waist goes way down they assess it
and they understand to do it better
I don't think we should vote against
this bill for that reason
further discussion from the committee
yes gretson Woodcock just responded to
the previous speaker
um
and I agree representative Damon uh
because she's the most knowledgeable in
this Committee of anyone nutrition and
diet work that being said
I would rather have a little waste and
feed those folks from 180 to 300 they
give them nothing to eat
and that's what you're saying give
nothing to eat because I don't want to
I'm saying Fairfield
just to be clear
that is not what I'm saying that is
absolutely not what I'm saying
any school district can choose to fund
any food program that it wants to fund
in its District
what we're talking about is increasing
the state mandate on all schools all
public schools about what they shall do
relative to serving food and so with all
due respect representative we can have a
difference of opinion but I would
appreciate it if you would not
mischaracterize the position that I'm
trying to articulate thank you Mr Jim
welcome
I do have one other question if in fact
you are like some communities which we
know that are serving programs which are
not the federal program they're serving
their own nutritious meals is this
person Belcher
if I made from the way that I read the
bill it does look like it's reimbursable
but not in their current programs it
would force them onto the federal school
you make a great point there are there
are five schools in the state as soon as
another War six is five now but that's
right we we went to the answer of study
there's five now um but that's not the
point you're absolutely right Rick and I
don't I don't know that
um I don't know that answer
um if they would be able to participate
uh for the ones above the state money I
don't know that and that's a great
that's a great question but they we
clearly there'd be a lot we wouldn't
force it on them they don't take it at
now I mean the amendment which is what
we're going to be talking about took all
those extraneous pieces out of there so
just the schools that are participating
they could I think it would be eligible
it's probably like concerned but you're
right that five is a question
okay you have one last comment represent
Damon
yes thank you Mr chair so
I'm looking at the amendment but the
paragraph I'm looking at in um Roman
numeral number one is the same as the
original bill
it does not require the federal program
so if we're getting stuck on that that's
not part of the spill
it says to make the meals available
it says
the State Board of Education style
established ensure compliance with this
section I'm on line 10 and 11 and shall
establish minimum nutritional standards
for such meals as well as income
guidelines Etc et cetera it does not
mandate the federal programs
this bill also speaks to the eligibility
requirements for free and reduced meals
that is the federal program
so I I think that what you're saying is
and not really giving us that the
specific information which is in this
bill we are talking about the federal
program
right
thank you Mr chairman um
again
does this apply to Charter Schools and
is it are these schools eligible for the
waiver that's in the rest of section 189
11a
further discussion
okay Madam Kirk we have a motion on the
do you ever
have a clarification that we are that we
would just asking questions or making
comments on the bill and not the
amendment is that correct that's correct
okay the motion on table is the initial
okay so we're going to address that
motion at this time it's 572 pre and
reduced meals
Madam Clark would you please what are we
voting on
chairman lad
yes
representative Orville yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford no
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald no
representative Noble yes
representative
yes
representative yes representative Myler
no
representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no representative
Luna no representative Ellison no
representative Wilcock no representative
Hall no Representative balbooni no
Representative cascadin no
representative Damon no
eight years 12 News
emotion fails
another motion representative Hall yeah
let's take him to teach you I'd like to
or not the amendment also at the pass
yeah no this is the main Bill you're
let the clerk catch up here so we have
OTP made by ripson Hall second by
representative Damon represent Hall your
record recognized for discussion
I think I've we've said everything that
needs to be said
okay represent Damon
okay
representative Ellison
Amendment uh
2023-0904 H uh to 527. okay
so representative Ellison has put on the
0-0904 h
okay
and there's a second from representative
Woodcock uh represent Allison you
recognized
represent Woodcock no thank you
yes my question is on part two section
one
which line starting in line 22 or 24.
thank you
um I'm in the introductory paragraph of
RSA 19839
one to read as follows
and I realize that you're adding in
disbursements for School meals but what
is not in there
um
EFA is amongst other things
we had a bill to
collect up all of the extra things and I
am not sure what happens having
collected up those extra things if we
then pass a bill because usually it's
the second bill
it's the later bill that takes
precedence and this would be the later
Mr chair yes yeah
um I I think this brings up a a good
point particular for newer members but
oftentimes legislative Services
um sees different bills that come
through that may amend different parts
of something and then during the
enrolled Bill process uh well actually
it's prior to the enrolled Bill process
legislative Services Smooths out those
those things isn't that correct Mr chair
so will the things that we
last week
go in in spider
this
you bring up a good point and
I think that's something which would
have to be checked with
OLS I've had this go around with them
before
and they have come down and looked at
the most recent legislation which
superseded the legislation that had been
written prior to
if they're on similar topic which is
this is on the same topic I mean this
section right here
so at this point in time I will call a
recess and trying to get some
clarification on this
and
well you know
LL Beans at the other side of the
highway
so we're going to take about five or ten
minutes till I get a response from the
clerk's office on this
hmm
yeah
we took out that comma so we're ready to
go to that next but we gotta get this
results
[Music]
[Laughter]
police
[Music]
but this is not changed
I don't think this will impact it
because this is an introductory
paragraph for that program
so this is where underneath that program
within the education trust when I spoke
as Paul said where is the reference to
where the monies come out to for the out
of that fund for efas I don't think it
and the other answer is it's the one
that's not that it's one that's
enacted
first
at the end of the whole process so which
one sign and the law works is one of the
supersedes
okay the uh
the way I understand this right now is
the one that's signed into
law last is the one that supersedes
however then the other side of the coin
is you have to look at what part of the
education trust fund is this this is an
introductory paragraph for School meals
not where you would have efas show up
within that trust so
and I spoke with the clerk about that in
the office eyeball the eyeball
and so it's it's the my opinion right
now that this language right here would
negate other language which we've
already done
so my question and brought this it
didn't it because it doesn't just say
School meals and add this to it it lists
out things that don't have anything to
do with school meals like
um
low in moderate income property tax
relief School building Aid all of those
that's current law
foreign
law
right
right but didn't we just that's that was
my point it's it is the section that
efas that we just put under isn't it
yeah it's it's yes
in the the um the section that
establishes the education trust fund
which begins with this
right and so this is adding
Define distribution of School meals and
there's another bill that adds to fund
education Freedom accountants
if both bills pass both those right so
it would be mine in underneath the trust
I sure hope so well that's how it works
because he just said the last one to get
and this would be the last one that
would be that would be if if
this Bill said said
um well if you had if you had two
uh Bill's addressing some of the same
thing like an EFA to bring it to 500 and
EFA to bring it to 350. right
right okay then would they look at the
last last correct yes that's correct
okay
so thank you basically I don't think you
know that that should be a concern in
regard to this amendment okay thank you
yeah
so where were we on the action here
Ellison
yeah well okay first name's all I need
right here
not seeing any hands requests for it
okay ma'am Kirk would you please call
the role
I mean this on the amendment thank you
it's on the amendment
chairman Ladd no
Representative barville no
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes
representative Belcher no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no
representative pedernal
no Representative no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Wilcox yes representative
Hall yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascadin yes
representative Damon yes
your proposed OTP we were just doing the
amendment
so no TPA now presented by
representative Miler and second
Holland Damon okay
they they had the OTP so they're they're
doing the otpa ocpa yes okay so
representative Hall and representative
Damon
otpa further discussion
uh chairman Ladd no
representative Orville no Representative
blackis no
representative Ford
yes
representative Belcher no representative
dry no representative McDonald yes
representative Noble no
Representative no representative
Portillo no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes 12 EAS eight
Nays
thank you
okay you don't have to decide right now
we can uh work on it
okay
okay 573 is a bill dealing with limiting
the EFA funding
do I have a motion
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair on
573 I would move itl
is there a second second
okay represent Belcher do you have any
discussion yes thank you Mr chair
um
so the way that I the way that I view
this bill and I think the the most
significant problem that I see with it
is that
as it stands our efas are a part of our
funding for inadequate education for
students
um now I personally have a very nuanced
view of the courts I think I might argue
that the legislative branch is
prescribed a certain amount of Supremacy
but this committee does put a lot of
difference on Court decisions and the
court has instructed us that we will
provide an adequate education and
because efas are part of that formula to
outright restrict the budgeting of that
I believe would actually violate that
Supreme Court ruling
I don't think that was something we want
to be playing with I think we need to
allow this popular program to be
accessed by the students who want to use
it the parents who want to use it
and
that's what I'll say about it thank you
further discussion from the committee
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chair
this bill is contradictory to previous
discussions we have regarding the EFA
program I think actually I know the
program is successful but not speaking
to the merits of the program but to the
bill itself to those who see flaws in
the EFA program and in the freedom
accounts
why would you limit a program's funding
a program can't be successful if you cut
its funding so if someone sees flaws
with the program this would just create
more flaws so it just really is
contradictory to the whole narrative
being spewed in this committee with all
due respect
further discussion represent Luna
thank you very much Mr chair
um a couple points this um the bill
before you does not actually cut funding
uh to a program in fact it establishes
funding for the program as opposed to
the blank check that it is right now uh
we heard from um from one member of the
public Ms Dunham who um who said what we
really need to be doing is advocating
for adequate funding for our public
schools and not not issuing a platinum
card with no credit limit
um that's um because that's that's how
the education Freedom accounts are
currently are currently run what um what
573 would do is actually impose some
financial responsibility some fiscal
responsibility into the school voucher
program by actually having the um the
department
advocate for how much money should be
should be distributed every year to
students through the education Freedom
accounts and not have it be the blank
check as the legislative budget office
assistant has
has called it in the past so um so I
believe this tightens it up I also
passed around
Amendment
0774h which cleans up an error in
drafting down online some uh line 12 by
it for a summary it just it it it left
in the words between not and shall
towards the end of line 12 it would take
that out and um
and the amendment would also
specify that the general fund is a
source for um uh for the efas so that's
Amendment 774 and
um and that's really all I've got to say
on both those
further discussion representative lekkas
and then representative Breville
get a bunch of school-aged kids moved
into the state
would we then tell them I'm sorry we
representative verville
thank you Mr chairman so it's it's
an interesting argument that I just
heard because my understanding of the
EFA program is that the the grant is
well defined in law per pupil so it
limits the per pupil spending of the
participants so to cap
the amount of money that's available is
essentially a back door at capping at
limiting
participation
into the the program so
if we do that on a wildly popular and
that's my editorializing
but at least a clearly popular program
what we're going to set up is uh you
know some get and some don't so it's
going to be how quickly you apply who
gets the funding first so now we're
pitting student against student family
against family by by capping a program
that the only the only car block that's
available is if all students move to the
EFA program
and while the participation in the
program has outstripped expectations
I'll grant you that
um it it certainly is is not a system
that's spinning out of control we don't
see 10 20 30 50 of students leaving
public schools for EFA programs so I
would I would say at this time that that
this type of move would be ill-advised
we should continue on as we are for a
couple of years my guess is that we're
probably close to the plateau of what
that program participation is is likely
to be and so I would say
um we should support the itl motion so
that we can see where the the natural
ceiling of participate participation in
the New Hampshire EFA program is thank
you Mr chairman you're welcome
representative Tanner
thank you um I was actually on the
committee I think there's a few other
people here back when uh the EF the
education tax credits started and then
the EFA started and I remember that
there was a very distinguished
representative from Hillsborough
who spoke quite eloquently about the
expense of this program and and how uh
it could easily spin out of control and
how one of the things that he really
pushed was a cap on this program
we've seen several a lot of bills come
through with the EFA program with the
educational tax program and
um
for some reason we don't get a fiscal
note with that it's often missing uh I
think almost in all cases it's missing
it's considered undeterminable or the
Department of Education hasn't gotten
the appropriate information to make
a physical node and that's particularly
since we had the first fiscal note for
the EFA programs which severely severely
underestimated what the program was
going to cost
as far as caps are concerned for example
special education cat Aid is based on
the total number of money of monies the
total amount of monies within that
program and if there's more it's then
divvied out so that the total amount
that often schools receive is down
around 50 percent of what they actually
spent
so we have caps in in the education fund
we have caps on different
um other vouchers that we give snap
programs
um you know and it and it's unfortunate
that we can't
uh just open the doors and say you know
let's take the billion dollars that
Surplus in the budget and uh put it all
in education but that doesn't seem to be
happening
so since that isn't happening and since
we have to be physically conservative
which I agree to
um I think a cap is necessary thank you
further discussion representative
Belcher thank you Mr chair I would just
I would just add because there is there
is some concern about the the money side
of this and and that's fair but the
limit to spending on this is not
infinite even the theoretical limit is
limited to the number of students we
have in New Hampshire and even that
theoretical limit will not be hit
however
if it were hit we do know that right now
the money that we're spending or the
money that we're giving to uh EFA
students in this grant
compared to the average cost to educate
a student in public or Charter Schools
it would result in about an 80 reduction
in costs to educate now that's not going
to happen nobody here thinks that's
going to happen not all students are
going to go for efas who knows how many
more will I doubt it's going to be a
huge percentage more than we already
have but we're talking cost savings here
not cost increases
up represent balbourney
um actually you you are talking about
kind of sitting here's um increases for
districts because there's a whole bunch
of students in districts right now that
are currently in private schools that
are not a burden on the local districts
if I may yes you absolutely have a point
that students who are already perhaps in
private schools who now access these
funds would be an additional
burden on taxpayers however from an
ethical side you have to make the
argument that somebody who pays taxes
and as a resident in the state should
not have access to funds per the Supreme
Court decision for an adequate education
second the amount of students that are
coming from or in private schools in
this state compared to those who are
accessing through this program it's not
even a trade-off when it comes to that
80 percent number that is the cost of an
EFA program versus the average cost of
the public school education student
representative miler
well on that point I think unless I'm
incorrect
it's been reported at this committee
that there has been 3 200 students who
are in the EFA program and a hundred
were from public schools that means 3
100 were already in private schools and
were not a burden or were not part of
the local cost for education
represent McDonald
thank you Mr chair just to quickly
correct that statistic that was the
previous year attending a public school
there were students within that figure
who had attended a public school
previously just maybe not during the
previous Academic Year or maybe the year
prior the year prior to that but they
were in public schools to an extent as
well
representative reveal
thank you Mr chairman it's another one
of these sort of interesting which way
are we choosing to to look at the Statue
type of questions because what I hear
from the other side of the aisle is that
the state
should pick up a much larger burden of
funding public education in the state of
New Hampshire
and we can agree or disagree on on that
fact but I think we all have to agree
that the EFA program is actually a 100
percent
state level funded program
it's a voluntary program it's a program
that people choose to participate in
and then the the funding is a hundred
percent state so it's it's a it's a
property tax relief
at the local level for for local public
schools I mean it's
I I have to admit I'm confused because I
would think that there are members on
this committee that would think that
this would be a dream come true that
this is providing an adequate education
according to the the parents and the
families of the participants and it's a
hundred percent
state funded and and not a burden on the
local taxpayer I would I would think
that this would be a win-win-win thank
you Mr chairman
I'd like to add that we've gone through
capping of adequacy in the past I can
recall back what was it 14 15 something
like that where we capped the amount of
money some of the schools in the
southern part of the state could receive
we couldn't have any more growth than
106 or 108 percent so we capped what
they would get they should have gotten
more for adequacy what happened there
was a suit that came back against the
state saying that's unconstitutional and
we had to end up paying those school
districts the money which they were
deserving to have initially so capping
any program like this that has to do
with uh funds for the opportunity for an
Mr chair so we're going to have to agree
to disagree on on that particular Point
um there's been no lawsuit ever filed in
the state of New Hampshire alleging that
the state is failing to provide an
adequate education for all its students
because it's not paying for private
school tuition bills and um and neither
decision in the conval cases or the
Londonderry case issue that the state
meets its constitutional obligations uh
for educating all of its children by
providing an opportunity for an adequate
education through public schools in
every
school-age child in the state of New
Hampshire has access to that opportunity
through Public Schools if they choose to
go do something else that's a choice
they make on their own and the state's
not denying them access to an adequate
education because the state is making
that available to them through their
Public Schools there's not a
constitutional argument
for um for for for for
um uh uh capping or or limiting to
budgeted amounts the education of
freedom freedom account program in fact
there's not even a constitutional
argument to completely uh um repeal the
education Freedom account program uh but
there is a constitutional argument when
the state decides not to fund at 100
percent the cost of an adequate
education as defined by Statute for
school districts like Dover and Bedford
who are only getting getting paid 95
percent of um of their cost of
inadequate education so the state was
right to lose that case and those
districts were right that the state was
not living up to its constitutional
obligation but the state has no
constitutional obligation insofar as the
school Voucher Program
I would just repeat what one efa's
parents said
after listening to all these arguments
what are my kids garbage
because her kids can't get an adequate
education at the public school because
they have special needs that
and various other things that won't be
met
how many how many parents do we have
come in here and say their kids weren't
getting inadequate even an opportunity
for an adequate education because they
were being bullied incessantly because
their EFA their um
special needs weren't being met and so
now we're telling them uh
sorry you don't count only the kids
going to the public so For Whom the
public school Works counts and if Public
Schools as they are now don't work for
you
and your parents can't afford to
to send you to a private school you're
just out of luck
okay I'd like to unless there's
something that's Earth shaking here in
our discussion I think we're probably
going to come out with a similar typo
we've been experiencing
so
um not seeing any requests for further
discussion Madam clerk would you
foreign
lad yes
representative Orville yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal
yes representative quartz yellow yes
representative Myler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner nope
representative Luna no representative
Ellison no representative Luca no
representative Paul no representative
Balboni no Representative cascaden no
representative Luna Mr chair thank you
I'll move uh uh to pass second
and um and we'll get we go through this
part quickly I'll move ought to pass on
the amendment that was um distributed
okay we have a motion on the table to
OTP uh 573 made by reps on luno second
by representative miler
represent luno has the floor for
discussion he's recommended otpa with an
amendment what was that amendment number
zero seven seven four h okay zero seven
seven four h I'd like to move that with
discussion I think we've had full
discussion on all this I could go right
to it
I know and further discussion
okay Madam clerk yes represent cascadden
just a brief comment I think it's a
shame if we start making laws for the
further discussion
so I'm gonna be okay with a hand vote on
this I'd be okay with the hand so this
is uh a hand vote on OT on on the
amendment zero zero seven seven four h
this is just on the amendment
okay all those in favor
so twelve to eight in favor of the
amendment
12 to 8.
all in favor rate opposed
pardon me
okay now we're at the main motion as uh
uh or the motion OTP as amended with
that's made by representative luno
okay Madam clerk would you please call
the roll chairman Ladd
no representative Orville no
representative Lucas no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative try no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative pedernal no
Representative courtiello no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Wilcox
representative Hall yes representative
Balboni yes representative Cass cabin
yes representative Damon yes
10 years 10 days
okay uh we're on the last show for today
this is HP 649 collection of State
okay okay we're going to take a short
but once you go get it we're going to
take a break for a second yeah we got
another bill this is gonna he's going to
have to get the amendment for 5 30. the
okay so if anybody has to go to the
necessity or whatever they call it the
WC
necessary latrine
head
bathroom remember them using that phrase
in the that word in the musical 1776.
yeah that's yeah in the book that clerk
they had that in the book 1776 which is
used by the intermediate school kids
yes the plague of 1776 down in
Philadelphia
looks good
bye
foreign
everybody looks like they're back in the
room so if we can get Cedar we can get
so I brought my gavel today and slimed
it
representative Ford we're ready to go
right
as I'm calling it yeah we've had it
okay for the next bill I'm going to hand
it off to uh representative uh Ford
the gavel
yes I'd like to make the motion on itl
and 649 collection of State education
property tax second and that second by
representative Miler excuse me that
represent for you okay I have no comment
representative Ford anyone else with a
comment on this any further comments
not seeing not okay it's back in my
hands now
not seeing any we're going to ask Madam
clerk uh for call the roll this is HB
649 the motion is itl made by
representative Ladd second by
chairman lad yes
representative verbal yes representative
Lucas yes representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative courtiello yes
representative miler
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Ellison yes
representative
Paul yes representative Falcone yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes
and I'm pleased to say 20 yes 08s any
objections to consent
thank you
okay we're gonna head right back up
north there to 5 30.
withdrawal from a co-op
we had a motion I believe was it art
OTP
on the floor and I believe there's an
amendment that's come forth represent
Belcher do you have that Amendment yes
thank you Mr chair I'd like to introduce
Amendment
zero nine five five H to HP 530.
um what I've done what we discussed
about uh this bill was to clarify that
um that comma that was located in the
wrong spot down on lines nine through
ten to make that part clear and we've
also struck the provision that would
allow a super majority
of the no vote from keeping a town from
being able to leave
the district with the hopes that that
would be able to um
restart a negotiation for
uh towns that have been significantly
impacted by changes in their real estate
value or demographics and such over time
another discussion
representative Luna
yes thank you very much Mr chair and so
the way I'm reading this is that it
makes it very clear that
either a um
a
vote of the co-op
a majority vote of the co-op uh uh in
favor of withdrawal plus a majority vote
of the withdrawing District in favor of
the withdrawal is sufficient to to do a
withdrawal or that a three-fifths vote
of the district who wants to withdraw
um that by itself would also be
sufficient to uh for the district to
withdraw yes that's correct thank you
so we have a motion for a the amendment
zero nine five five h
did we have most to for that
Amendment
I would move ought to pass on Amendment
zero nine five five H okay we got now in
a second do we have a second second
okay now is there any further discussion
yes representative Luna yeah thank you
Mr chair so so wouldn't this um you know
if this were to become law this would
basically say any uh any District that
wants out of a co-op any pre-existing
District that wants out of a co-op
three-fifths sixty percent vote of just
that just the voters in that
pre-existing District not the voters in
the overall Co-op just the voters in
that pre-existing District would be
sufficient to um for um for a district
to pull out of a co-op so um so
virtually
well actually it would apply to any
District anybody that wants out
I want to get out and um and doesn't
matter how much
bonded debt or Debt Service or other
encumbrances or anything else that might
be be going on and this thing I suppose
they'd have to work that out but um but
but essentially
um
any um
any pre-existing District
or municipality I guess that's a member
of a of a co-op if they want out they
get out they don't they don't have to
work out anything with the um
with the co-op District
and and I think that's just really
dangerous I think that that defeats the
whole purpose of having Co-op agreements
I understand there's problems with Co-op
agreements but my god let's fix the
co-op agreements then
um and and you know let's provide maybe
some balance to uh to it you know we
heard testimony today from from attorney
Christina that that over the last what
couple of decades there's been a handful
of districts that have um have pulled
out a co-op so so for some of these
districts the um
the current laws is is enabling that but
this just seems like a really radical
way of um of renegging on a uh on an on
an existing contract and and you know I
I know we we hear a lot well this is the
way we do things and stuff like that but
um but you know these are private
contracts and and now we're now we're
giving one party in a contract the
ability to renege on that contract and
um
um you know maybe in the maybe in the
case of Carol it's not going to be
devastating to the to the rest of the
co-op I guess I really don't know that
but um but quite possibly for a lot of
other Cooperative districts uh uh you
know especially if if maybe one of the
one of the bigger municipalities in The
District in the co-op I mean decides to
withdraw that could be devastating and
um and it could cause local property tax
rates to that haven't already gone
through the roof to go through the roof
um plus they're doing this without any
input from from the co-op so
um I I think this is this is very
dangerous territory
foreign
it's not entirely without regard to
the property Etc does say a withdrawal
plan shall be prepared and shall provide
for the disposition of property held
within the cooperative
and a statement of assumption of
liabilities
but
if you know that a small District can
leave
I would think you would be quick to come
back to the table and see what their
complaints are
and see if you guys can come to an
agreement so they don't want to leave
for instance with Carol I suspect if it
was 50 50 instead of 40 60 they may well
I am quite hesitant in voting for this
amendment as it is when we've taken that
last part of the sentence in part two
out
I really am I mean I I believe that
represent cordelli who's the maker of
this bill would also be very very
hesitant
so what I'm going to do at this time
because I I don't see this is hitting
the mark
I'm going to recess this meeting until
tomorrow until Wednesday and when
representative cordelli is back here and
we'll pick it up exactly where we are
right now and I want everybody to
consider uh that I believe there needs
to be a vote
of the whole District it can go two ways
here
and um that's what I I believe that
representative cordelli and I had
discussed with numerous people Beyond
this committee to try to ascertain and I
think this by doing this we are going
back to uh more conflict if we went with
this so at this point in time we're done
with this for today
and we will come back and pick this bill
up uh on Wednesday and so this this
particular bill is in recess until
Monday we'll announce that and we'll
continue the exact session for 5 30 at
that time on Wednesday at five uh we'll
come back and deal with 5 30 on
Wednesday
yes
the query around the start time for
Wednesday
um should it be continue to be 9 30. I'm
just concerned does anybody have a more
recent weather report as far as when the
storm is supposed to be concluded and
are we going to be able to have uh
Road access uh I'm particularly
concerned about those who are coming
from a long distance here and whether or
not starting like even like at 10
instead of 9 30 might help those
traveling from long distances well you
know represent Milo I'd be more
concerned about not those coming from
Conway or from Haverhill or from Berlin
which are used to driving in this stuff
be concerned about those coming in from
okay but looking at our what we have
we have including the bill today sends
two three four five six seven eight
bills which is very doable
um the bills though
um carry a a lot and then and they're
important in fact the first one 452 uh
dealing with school building Aid
I understand There's issues occurring
with school building Aid right now in
finance that we should be aware of
and
um so 452 is important
um
and all as they all are so please uh
look these over so we can scoop through
them if we run out of time if it's
really short we'll put the limit on who
can speak and who can't as far as you
know numbers we were able to get out by
3 30 that's that's my you know turning
into a pumpkin's time Rick do we have an
yes we do and and I had that see yes I
did and it dealt with taking forwards
out there up top charitable yeah that's
what we talked about yeah what we talked
about in the work session
um we're talking about the um the the
building age process yes yeah and
getting rid of gifts and stuff like that
that's right yeah and just keeping state
federal dollars and we'll we'll explain
that when we discuss because that part
is very very important to one of the
schools receiving aid this year yeah in
order for that to happen
could you could you send it could you
email me a copy of yeah I I think I oh I
haven't got it back from him yet but
when I do get it back I I gave it to him
on Friday and I told him I have to have
it by Wednesday yeah if I get back some
I'll go over and ask him today yeah yeah
okay
um represent four did you have something
you want to say quickly to the committee
very quickly I just wanted to draw your
attention to some news it has nothing to
do with New Hampshire or us it has to do
with education of children something
like eight or ten young men black men in
New Orleans have won more than a million
dollars collectively in scholarships for
their academic performance on the
standardized tests
did you say it just for me it's
wonderful
in the last note on Wednesday you come
in bring your computers March Madness is
beginning
and that's something you got to watch
even during session you have my
permission
just keep your eyes on Duke
thank you very much and have a safe